this takes me back to because you
mentioned it
all this amazing work for the original
Saturday Night Live then you go and
you're the first head writer for the
launch of Late Night with David
Letterman
well Meryl Marco was the very first I
feel I took over for Barrel who was at
the time Dave's live-in girlfriend so
you can imagine the the pressure of
um and she desperately that I had met
with I'd been a fan of Dave's morning
show that he did in summer of 1980 that
only lasts about six months that's the
summer that I was in a senior in high
school and I saw that and it it it tore
the top of my brain open I just I just
thought what is this it was my mother
who turned me on to that show and and
because it was a daytime show so it's
the kind of thing I wouldn't have been
exploring right at that time of day
anyway and she said I think you'd really
love this David Letterman is marvelous
he's just so funny and and so I started
when I go normally I don't go to my mom
for you know movie recommendations or TV
but I uh I you know I said this is
really funny and and so when he was
started his late night show he made an
inquiry about my availability and I I
just want to meet him so I I knew I was
committed to this to this uh film thing
that that ended up going nowhere but so
I did so I I was I went in and I said
like and I had a package of stuff and
from the show right and um some other
ideas and they said oh we really love
your stuff we want you to be the head
writer and I said uh I well I I do want
to do it but can I can we like rain
check it and do a little later and they
were and so anyway so I but I
recommended other writers like George
Meyer George Meyer one of the greatest
and Max Frost and Tom Gamo and and um
and uh that lineup was incredible yeah
they found Andy brackman on their own
and I recommended Steve O'Donnell
um and so that was like the nucleus of
that staff that's a great
writing staff and and
um and then I joined the show like
I remember like my 30th birthday
fell the first week of our show and I I
was like three hours late to this my own
birthday party because we were reading
small town news and looking for like
goofy things go A few things that Dave
could talk about but um yeah that was a
I mean I'm just thinking about to try
and uh I don't know just to be there for
the beginning of SNL
and then to be there at pretty much the
beginning of the of uh of
Late Night with David Letterman and as
you know it's the beginning of these
shows that's always to me the part where
the real Foundation gets laid
the sensibility is set and I I think
that's true of so many of these shows I
think it was true for for my show and
then you can evolve it beyond that but
it's really that beginning that's that's
so crucial and to have that experience I
mean I remember that show was the show
I'd have given uh my bone marrow to work
on that show
that was my dream was to work on that
show and I I applied and got very close
and didn't get it and is that true yeah
and then it was just that was after I
was going yeah after you were gone and
then uh you're at SNL and then I get
hired at SNL you know my life has
changed so much Sona has it yeah let me
tell you how I can just get all this
stuff delivered right to my door I mean
if you grew up when I did in the early
1920s that was unheard of you know a kid
in a cap you had to hey boy boy you know
and you'd have to say yes sir and you'd
have to say you know toss him a coin go
get me that goose in the window and he'd
say yes sir Mr Scrooge but it was that
was was like back then yeah but now it's
not so much of our world digitized and
automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail or ship
often let stamps.com do the hard part
for you simply print Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes no
long lines or complicated setup required
it's the easiest so it's the best yeah
postage rates just increased again hello
luckilystamps.com has the best discounts
in the industry avoid the hassle and get
started with stamps.com today sign up at
stamps.com Conan for special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com Conan you kind of
uh you you
appreciated
whatever thing I had you appreciated it
right away and that made meant the world
to me like that was that was a huge deal
for me that you I think anyone would
have uh in my position I don't think you
were like a
you know it wasn't like you were a
diamond in the rough you know you you um
well I think anyone you really yeah it
was I I what I remember is you told me
you identified something you said
Conan you're very funny when you're back
on your heels you said when you're when
you're slightly off kilter and playing a
part where you're kind of off balance uh
it's very funny and I think I I thought
about it since because you put that in
my head that in the all these years 30
years now being
in front of the camera
it's my recovery that people really
laugh at do you know what I mean a lot
of the time it's my oh yeah it's my uh
readjusting myself and saying well well
what I meant was in that kind of Bob
Hope Woody Allen way uh and and you know
uh just a couple of weeks ago Harrison
Ford yelling at me going okay all right
well you know you have to understand and
that's what people really like it's the
and you identified it very early on
which was was it it's a great move and
and and uh yeah I mean but I mean you do
all kinds of things that I think are
really funny but also a contortionist
which you didn't know oh I yeah yeah I
can get my leg completely behind my head
oh don't do that oh there's a terrible
ripping when I do it